in our nation's capital an angry mob
harassing and threatening senator rand
paul and his wife
after leaving president trump's speech
last night here he is
earlier today reacting they were
shouting
threats you know to us to kill us to
hurt us
but they're also threat saying shouting
say her name briona taylor
and it's like you couldn't reason with
this mob but i'm actually the author of
the briona taylor law
to end no knock raids so the irony is
lost on these idiots
that they're trying to kill the person
who's actually trying to get rid of no
knock raids
the agitator is also confronting other
people on their way out and clashing
with police
greg obviously these are just peaceful
protesters
exercising their first amendment rights
right
i feel bad when he was just trying to uh
use some reason
and explaining they don't care whether
he sponsored that bill
they're just out for a scalp but and
remember this is a precursor to
escalating violence so if you deny that
this is a serious event
then you are culpable in future events
right because this is how it starts
this is what was laughed at by people at
cnn and elsewhere
of this kind of idea just months ago
laughing at this sort of thing and then
when it becomes political expedient to
condemn violence they will do it
um cloud research today did some
research and found that 12 percent of
republicans
do not report their true opinion about
their uh preferred candidate in polls
and it's a it's about 11 percent
independence they call it the shy
voter this is why the mob
you cannot express there are people in
the united states
who have more freedom of speech than you
do
think about that think about that if you
put on that trump hat
you're gonna get your ass kicked and
people could say that's bs
no we know it i watched enough of these
videos and each time these videos are
played
you create more shy trump voters trust
me
the democrats better get in front of
this or they will forever
be the party of the mob and they will
deserve it
katie we all know senator paul was
attacked
at his house i think he had some ribs
cracked
um so when this something like this
happens
again it's um there's some bad memories
there
this is the third time that senator rand
paul has survived
leftist violence he was attacked as you
mentioned by his neighbor had a
punctured lung had very serious surgery
and then he was on the same baseball
field
as steve scalise when a bernie sanders
supporter tried to kill as many
republicans as possible
during the congressional baseball
practice and here we are with the third
time
greg brings up greg brings up democrats
not standing up to the mobile they've
actually been encouraging the mob he had
maxine waters
in 2018 saying that you need to harass
trump supporters wherever they are make
them uncomfortable in department stores
at the grocery store anywhere you see
them make them uncomfortable
you had kamala harris earlier this
summer when asked about the protesters
and she said they will not stop and they
should not stop they're not going to
stop on election day and they're not
going to stop after
election day so it's not that they
haven't you know they're just cowards
who don't want to address this they've
actually engaged
in encouraging and promoting this kind
of behavior
juan your reaction to what you saw on
the videotape
well i just think it was an ugly scene
and something like that jesse could
escalate
quickly because with mobs you know one
person acts and then everything goes out
of control
in a rapid series so i think that's an
ugly scene i don't like it but you know
keep in mind the police were right there
to guard the senator and his wife
and you're allowed to yell at
politicians that's america i mean i
remember
i think it was 2010 when the tea party
surrounded a bunch of
democrats going into the congress at the
capitol
uh to complain about uh obamacare and
there was heckling and shoving going on
right then and there
so i'm glad the police were there you
were glad the police were there that's
good
the police were there yeah good
excellent so one
final thought on this which is i
i don't call for defunding biden doesn't
i think you like to
push out that that distortion anyways
one final thought
it's this is a this is uh what i saw
last night at this uh
event at black lives matter square which
is you know right by lafayette square
there was no riot there was no looting
there was very little violence at what
we went on last night that's far
different knocked out from
i said there was little violence i
repeat but i'd say that's far
different from what took place in
kenosha where you have a reported
militia member
killing i report i repeat killing two
people that's different than oakland
where you have
a far right guy killing a federal
security guard or minneapolis where you
have
a far right umbrella man walking around
smashing windows
so as to somehow i don't think you'll
learn more
on violence with politics no i'm not
going to say go there if you're going to
say this you're not on your side
let's
it wasn't too long ago that these same
people were surrounding statues
and putting ropes around them and trying
to pull them down those statues in all
the areas that we all walk and work when
we go to dc
are now completely barricaded by acres
of fencing
so now that they can't pull down statues
they're trying to pull down
human beings right they're shouting in
their faces they're trying to knock them
over so i don't know what comes next
but i have been walking the streets of
washington dc in new york my entire
adult life
and it is now not the same and i don't
know where this is headed i think it is
unnerving and just because nobody you
know what doesn't matter who's doing the
shooting and the pushing one
it's wrong across the board and the
murder of those two individuals in
kenosha
is a is an absolutely heinous crime for
which i
i would imagine the suspect is going to
go to jail probably for the rest of his
life
but violence is violence it doesn't
matter what's what's engendering it or
what's inspiring it but
this is not headed in a good direction
yeah uh
five side trying
one side trying to stop it right five
people last night arrested for
assaulting
police officers i don't recall that